please all come here is it
[Applause]
[Music]
see I don't even remember that I know I
used to talk about musicals because I
have a thing about you know people say
oh you're transgender you would like
musicals I don't it's not like I like
action movies how do you think I mean
your your house
speaking of you being an athlete before
you came here Wow and I think we use
that word advisedly I'm an endurance
runner there are Olympians and then I'm
an injury and I just I've very slow I'm
one of the slowest people in the world
people I run these marathons I don't
know a few things but I run multiple
marathons and I've run 27 and 27 days
but very slowly you know you know the
Olympic record but they're almost down
to two hours yeah and I'm almost up to
12 hours see I can do very long for one
matter I've had interviews on the same
day but I just took a long time I stop
and I talk to people and cows and dogs
and cats and things what I do it's a
holistic marathons I run when I feel
like running where I want to run I don't
run in organized marathons I run I just
go I'll go down there oh it's just you
yeah it's I mean they have quitted their
sport now left left at the top do you
think there is an age limit when it
comes to sports no well there shouldn't
be if you were 90 and you could beat
everyone and then good luck to you but I
think there probably is and and you know
Olympian athletes they're going to know
where that edge is I you know the
trouble is I suppose in sports it when
you get to 30 that's that's the clock
ticking but do you are you iron athlete
in the sense that you have the germ
paranoia as well no I think germs are
good for you you know like I I do the
other thing well you know Howard Hughes
did this thing you know the big
billionaire in America and he was doing
tissues and stuff in the germs but then
you don't build up the antibody so I do
it the other way around and I know I'm
sure you know professional as a very
good Olympian athletes they will have a
way of doing it but what I do is eat a
piece of dirt put a piece of dirt in
your food yeah
because think about it think about all
up you know for if you're from Norway
Sweden Britain Jonah vet wherever you're
from the whole world we've come from
people who were not living with
antiseptic hand wash yeah they were just
living in camps and things and they were
nomads and they got through it didn't
they they weren't god I mean they became
like 30 years old
yes but maybe that was because they were
just working so I don't know you have
you you're coming to to Sweden and
Norway touring the spring with the show
you called wunderbar wunderbar yeah
Germany yes Alice approach
well I've I'm against Breck's hate and
trumpet and all the negative right-wing
let's separate stick our heads in the
ground and go backwards for Humanity I
am for going
if you track linearity we gradually
learn to live together and work together
in some shape or form and if you take
Norway in particular Norway back of the
Vikings Norway used to zip over noise
your country yes yes yes so you used to
zip over and say can we just kill
everyone and take all the stuff chat
shows and stuff that's much nicer and we
this is this is the logic and we do this
and we see the sense of it the whole
thing of a purity of a race is nonsense
because we're all intermarried interlink
together and all languages interlinked
and it's difficult new European Union
very difficult I know no it's not it is
in the European Economic Area but it's
still the idea my thing is I perform I
develop my next show there's wound about
show in French too tough on say and I
will be back in Paris in December doing
it so if anyone can learn French by
December I'll be there during the game
French and I do it I improvise in French
and then because I wanted to redouble -
and this is all because of rex height
and trumpet well because if half my
country's going backwards and I'm gonna
go even further forwards and I
translated what I've developed in French
into German I went to Frieda Strasser in
Berlin and I did aleksef storage which
was session and a sphere at the same
time so and then I translate it into
English and I'm doing Spanish as well
and I want to do Russian and I want to
do Arabic but no Russian you don't speak
Russian no at the moment I say spasiba
privyet and the the hello in Russian is
really tricky it's much bigger but
previous is high and I know that one I
know spasiba it's receiver bought Shia
because Bolshoi Ballet is the great
ballet and specific portions is thank
you very much
[Laughter]
Russian is a tricky one but um you know
Germans a tricky one for me but we see
all Russian kids speak Russian or
Mandarin Chinese kids manner in Chinese
no languages that hard
you know what is this I mean it learning
your language yeah is that about a
talent or is it about determination
determination motivation above all
motivation and I can prove that anyone
can learn a language I've got this great
proof it's a logic proof someone says I
can't learn they don't know you had a
million time so I say what do you want
to learn they say Spanish they manage up
whatever I say let's go there for a
weekend and then as you go I'll tell you
to go ahead through customs I'll just
slip a block of heroin into your bag
that smuggling heroin that's my merit
they go to prison for ten years to life
and within one month they're doing basic
sentences in Spanish in general whatever
it is because the motivation will be I
better learn this language
it's just motivation and everyone goes
oh yeah I suppose so but because I came
out as transgender 33 years ago when we
were all children Wow and I got no front
cover of any newspaper at all I what I
did because I can set up artificial
emergencies I can set up you know back
in 85 there was no reason me as a
straight transgender person to come out
I could have lied like people have done
throughout millennia going backwards and
I thought no I'm the right person I
wanted to be in Special Forces I didn't
go into Special Forces so I did this
psychological you know civilian Special
Forces of coming out and taking all the
crap that I get in the streets that I
get less in the streets these days but
you know people shouting me people
fighting me I will deal with that but
this is a better place I've got to and
then people are more relaxed these days
in all our countries and always Sweden
where everyone's more relaxed this is
also about determination yes it's a
decision that you made yeah I'm a
determined little bastard yeah when you
when you're working I mean talk about
enduring pain I mean it's it's a the way
you work is that when you're preparing
for a tour now yeah you go on stage here
in London I I saw you the other night
yeah and it's like incredible because
you you walk on and you just start
talking yeah and part of it though of
course you you get huge lofts
some material you just make a little
note that how much pain can you endure
your well I don't think that's painful
it's like you when you're doing that
remember your first ever chat show that
you did that was probably pretty painful
no less painful yeah it's it's the
pressure it's what happens it's like
driving a car driving a car is a very
good example when we learn to drive a
car it was a nightmare and we're gonna
hit a human that cat a dog we're gonna
hit another car remember that those
times as well mirrors what stole its
talk all that pressure and now we do it
for three hours ago yes I know what you
mean yeah well I then oh we will have
these conversations well fiddle with the
radio with stuff of kids yeah I know
sure hang out word we're pretty good in
that car thing but that's an amazing
thing there's you track back through
humanity there's no reason we should be
able to drive these mirror signal
maneuver you know two-ton vehicles but
we can do it so the pressure gets less
that's it so as you saw me last night
the night before it was I'm not bothered
cuz if I can do it in French if I can do
it in German if I can improvise in
German then improvising in English it's
like free that's that's the trick I make
things artificially hard for myself and
then I get a gift of easiness back up
the ladder in English you're talking you
talked a lot about religion we I don't
believe in religion I mean it's great
it's a great area to go for well I just
pointed out the thing which I'm gonna
just discover this in the last few days
that no animal has religion you know no
Tigers ever go okay we're gonna go we're
gonna get the Antelope Jimmy you come in
the right flank I'll come on the left
back we'll go keep quiet then we'd go
for it on my on my car we'll all go for
it and now Padre if you could make a
prayer for to the gods
timmi the tiger we're gonna please help
us get in and get this antelope and rip
him to pieces in the most merciful way
that we can that just doesn't happen
so wait and you'd think that if a God
had made us all he would make sure
religions in all all the animals all
dogs should be praying every Tuesday at
half four or something but they're not
do any religion World War two is it
World War two that's the time he was
should have come down if he made us all
and we were praying like crazy and fifty
million dying and this idiot with the
moustache you know and that was the time
to come down and go what's that guy I'm
so sorry I'm God I'm sorry about that
Hitler guy think he's coming guys he
doesn't come for tsunamis he doesn't
come for earthquakes he doesn't come for
world wars he's not coming and
interestingly in Europe we have moved
away I think from God maybe our problems
going more towards rate but most of us
are moving away in America you saw if
you're going to get elected you have to
say god Bless America but in Britain if
we said god bless Britain everyone would
just look at you politically they just
go I don't know what you're talking
about even though God is still supposed
to be there somewhere
what would you would you ever I mean
have you have you ever in your life sort
of hoped that there was something there
have you have you have you prayed well
my mum died when I was six
and yeah I did pray I went to a school
we had no religion at home but from six
I went to a boarding school with my
brother
and they had a built-in Protestant
Church of England kind of a light
religion not not too heavy you know
let's sing a few his safe things there's
a guy Jesus the Jesus guy the Yeshua his
real name is Yeshua I love him I think
he's great guy you know and Muhammad
Muhammad as well they're very
interesting guys they're like Nelson
Mandela like Gandhi and have been women
as well great spiritual leaders but I
just don't think the floatie guys up
there I don't think this guy who comes
down and goes now everyone eat cheese or
something you know I just don't think
that I don't think he's there I've
noticed he's not do you remember in the
old days we used to say that God lives
in the clouds and he was always in the
clouds and then we've learnt to fly in
the last century through the clouds and
no one ever said he's not here was not
ever mentioned you know they should have
gone wet where is he he's not there it's
not on that cloud and it should have
been Jesus in the bath they're going I
wanna just pull the curtains up you know
there was no one in the clouds and we
always thought they were in the clouds
and whenever something gets disproved we
never make a marker on that we just move
on and go oh he's further up he's in the
stratosphere he's on Mars no he's three
planets over so I just don't believe in
the guy Eddie from from whom did you
inherit your sense of humor
this is dad my dad is a great sense of
humor he died this year mum died 50
years ago dad died this year in my show
I tell his final joke he made a joke to
him phoned my brother up and told this
joke and but he still had the sense of
humor and I've he was still they he had
lesions on his head cause he because he
had there's a bit of skin cancer had
been in a very hot country for eight
years in Yemen where we were born and
they said you're gonna have to have that
dealt with by his plastic surgeon and
then he said okay we said he's not
actually made of plastic is he he was
still coming out with funny lines even
though he was not having a great time of
life but yeah he he's the sense of humor
my brother's got the same sense of humor
how close were you as a family we were
close in a kind of kind of slightly
British way slightly pulled back emotion
away yeah there's a strong bond of love
there and we loved our mother and mum
went so long ago now but yeah so it was
great and my brother said he wrote an
obituary for the newspaper local
newspaper said if you can't get to
choose your parents but if we had been
allowed to choose our father we would
have chosen him and that was very nice
for my brother yeah I was yeah I think
so it was quite similar he was also
really active and hard worker so did he
train you heart was he like that this no
he'd never push us so she wouldn't push
him no absolutely he was never standing
with the word sure he drives to the
training smoking and looking race he was
calm guy and no pressure from the
parents at all so that was I was really
lucky Eddie I have to ask you before we
move on here you you talk a lot about
animals yes do you no no do you like yes
yes I'd like to feel I could walk up to
a tiger and say hello and look him in
the eye but I think he'd eat me if as
you are you are a politician a
politician I'm going to be a politician
after 2020 I'm standing to be a member
of parliament after first general
election after 2020 but I
[Applause]
alas I'm sorry but these people care
about them no no but in a spiritual way
you can but no but I think maybe the
applause is not necessary because they
may not know my politics but I'm for the
many not for the view I'm for humanity
I'm for this century we have a world
where 7.5 billion people everyone has a
fair chance that's what I'm fighting for
and I'm trying to live it I'm trying to
live politics so I'm performing in
French and German and Spanish I want to
perform in Arabic and Russian I want to
reach over to other countries and say hi
and can you learn from us can we learn
from you what can we all learn together
what can we we're all human beings we
come from the same place and I'm looking
for the connections as opposed to the
separations I think Breck's hate
trumpets for separation for we're better
than you the nationalism that old thing
of the 30s and we know what happened in
the 30s if you pick up a book you know
what happened so it's just not the place
to go so I will fight against that
everywhere so what do you think as a
thought experiment if our our animals
here in Britain yep were able to vote if
we gave them the right to vote right
where would you put them on the on the
map well then who is right who's left
that's a very silly question you realize
that is silly question I ever I think
they all vote against brexit
[Applause]
that question I am quite sure with my
connection with the animals I'd but some
of them wouldn't be sure but I've got
them and I'd say mr. tiger mr. lion
Kenny the drive just just trust me okay
we humanity we and the animals we've got
to do a partnership baby we got it head
forwards we got to go forwards rather
than backwards
you can't go forwards if you're going
backwards so and they would go yeah yeah
man yeah big I wouldn't race the cats no
no not the big cats not even some of the
small ones okay well they let you down
in the end
no would they they've they'll vote their
own way they probably abstain hope you
enjoyed the clip for more interesting
conversations please hit subscribe